I feel so much better not doing it I've
done it now for 15 days yeah I just feel
so much better you should see what
happens when you drink water for
somebody they have one with some no bun
the produce outside it stop okay here we
go
Steve loves those stones love those okay
oh my god would you just say god dammit
I told you this yesterday to make shakes
yeah even ready what shakes did they oh
there's more but I just said vanilla
shake I don't know top I don't know you
could fear this elevator oh wait don't
order yet the bosses throw a choc the
one in there borrow a little bit right
over there I already win hi anybody else
want shakes you're the boss
okay I'm so sorry I mean they were
already doing your guests so you're
excused
this happens every [ __ ] week every
week and they're the ones also like we
got to be on time that says it but
they're the only ones who think about
you so hard vanilla shake yeah you can't
have mine I might even then I'm not
gonna tell you what I got okay I want to
see those videos done on time you know
what editor it's up to you if you want
to keep this oh you want the world to
see how responsible we are what real
business entrepreneur hustle man
[Music]
it never to old news submitted by chief
of Chiefs I mean a 72 year old
grandfather teaches himself how to
produce hip hop I saw this he makes 12 E
sleep on 70 year olds fire - what is it
trapped in is pretty much like me goes
GZ who's me - oh [ __ ] I hate to say like
skirt yeah like just a random [ __ ] in
the background like this takes place in
Chicago this is our third boy 72 years
old
our third double knot like Dubois oh I
thought they were calling them like boy
boy
Du Bois yeah I like the boy better boy
here we go
good brother introduce yourself man and
tell me what you do man dr. Dubois
making beats yo man so my man came in
here today and he was looking for a
studio I talked about this is doing it
for the youth but you told me you was
young at heart and so he came in playing
this music good I just I had to play it
for somebody because man we got those
monitors same okay baby so let me get
this thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the producing for 60 years then
it's not at 66 not like he just taught
himself yesterday he's been making beef
but what's crazy though is like a sec
I'm from my mom's perspectives it's like
older people fear technology because
they don't understand it they didn't
grow up with it so it's just crazy
foreign thing to them he's already a
musician in another way maybe he was
tall super tall so he was saying that
you know all these years he heard the
music he felt like it was really good
music and he was filling it but he's
like they didn't have that back in my
day so he was really drawn to this type
of music and so he liked that bring with
creating some imagine he only did it
just for the girls I would I would be
tight he liked the scene as I'm like
this didn't happen when I was young [ __ ]
right yeah so then like all these years
he's just been like working on it on his
own he's been like really shy about it
and so finally he just mustered up the
courage to go yeah get some professional
producer feedback also he's been like a
closeted producer for six years yes
that's kind of dope he actually had his
contact for this studio for about three
years he finally came across that local
recording studio and so he was like oh
you know just finally I'm just gonna go
and so he went and then now this went
viral and so it's pretty awesome like I
want to see how like previous to this
what his secret obsession was like like
he's like a regular
grandpa right but when you go into his
bedroom he locks a door he has his
[ __ ] producing thing he turns off the
light if we turn to a studio yeah and it
he's like making his lap time yes he's
wearing it for the public and then he
sits down his chairs like trapped it's
like nephews come over he's like oh [ __ ]
and he has to hide everybody gets back
in his leg so you won't that be gritted
because they do mention that he did try
to get some pointers from his family
members yeah his grandson crap all like
not today man like we don't want to hear
it because he thought it was like old
timey music I thought it was gonna be
slow because he's all the thumbs gonna
be slower yeah
sounded like fruityloops remember man
everybody was on on the free version of
[Laughter]
its first software production programs
yeah for garage bear yeah yeah yeah yeah
so he's the father of two kids in their
30s and 40s he was a grandfather to
teenage grandchildren yes and now
everyone on the internet psycho awesome
like he's he said that he decided to
take this online as a hobby just to keep
his brain like exercise and I keep
Douglas crazy he is so much older than
hip-hop 80 30 30 44 years old yeah 40
maybe yes and trap music is 10-15 years
so what exactly is trap music it's hard
to explain but like ti it's a certain
kind of be like heavy on hi-hat heavy on
bass that well that okay that's that's
like really synonymous with trap music
Connor a lot of stuff that happens in
Atlanta is trap beats so T eyes first
album I think it's called trap music I'm
not sure something with trap in it yeah
but like him Jeezy Gucci man were like
the forefathers of trap and in the
instrument or the beat machine that they
use is like the 808 drum drum machine
it's an old school 90s like it's not a
synthesizer but it was it was a it was a
drum machine that had pre-recorded
sounds of bay
snare and it's very distinctive and they
still use that sound today cuz don't ya
so the producer like you went to his
name is Andre ad to Daniel's and so this
producer posted that video you guys just
saw on Twitter and then he just went
viral and so he that's when he told
Arthur about all the feedback that he
was getting he was just overwhelmed she
was like wow this is amazing I never
thought my beats would be this good you
guys would be reacting this way and so
after he heard about Twitter he created
his own Twitter how cute after he heard
about witters it's been a roller ever
now but he heard about it but like after
this response oh I want to get on so now
he has his own Twitter account and beats
by Arthur that's 72 year old Twitter
handle ever yeah
beats by Arthur I also wish they talked
about the conversation he had on on the
phone with his kid who was helping him
set up his Twitter account on the phone
exactly what exactly I'm there right now
yeah I got it up and I'm like well [ __ ]
is gonna take forever how I was setting
up my mom's gmail account
I'm like mom it's like actual mail
you're sending it to people but there's
no physical paper anymore like your
handle or whatever like your that's
literally your home address yep I'm like
well I shoulda never thought about that
like that you really have to break it
down you know she will address
electronic mail address yeah I got so
frustrated I never do so frustrated set
my mom up with her [ __ ] email that I
was just like listen what's your what do
you want your password to be well you
wanna hear maybe I'll [ __ ] do it for
you so I did it and then she couldn't
log in using the password that she gave
me you can't do there is no way to do
this yeah you got a teacher you gotta
teach him the philosophy so that if they
get stuck they can figure it out
Oh Mike is the caps lock on okay what
are you doing that do you know how to
spell what you told me to write
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] a man I have to teach my dad
from A to Z like how to use a computer
this is extremely like technology
illiterate so I wrote down instructions
because he only wanted to do if like a
few things I think one of us to check
his like mutual fund or something like
that so what he had to do is when I when
we turn on the computer I don't turn on
the computer
and I'll have to write down every image
that shows up like it's gonna make this
sound then whatever and then usually
like the top left icon it's highlighted
and has like a blue mark so he doesn't
know how to use a mouse that's too much
I would say that there's an arrow button
that goes like this click on that two
times and should put you on this icon
and have to draw like that overwhelms
the old people though you can't that's
what he wanted he'll follow that all the
way through Wow
- I call this week three icons baby like
it really takes that of you know like
she has all these she's fine my grandma
she has a Facebook and she facetimes all
the time - yeah he's 80
he always trips me out because he's
tech-savvy he's like hey do you have a
tick tock accounts - yeah exactly who'd
like so they just they just got they
were talking about coming over and my
mom was like oh why don't we take the
cab right so they just got off their
cruise um like and then they were coming
from Long Beach to my house and I was
like Oh have you heard of uber and he
goes oh yeah I can't believe I didn't
even think of that and then they just
uber it at my house and I was getting
ready to explain to him how to use uber
and maybe he just turned eight it's
amazing he was like oh he's like yeah I
didn't even know like because they don't
use that in Japan right they just use
cabs and trains yeah so it was like oh I
didn't even think of that and I'm like
he was like oh you know what it was way
cheaper than using a cab it was like 40
bucks and I'm like dang dude like my
getting so ready to tell him the steps
right right I'd have to say [ __ ] it's
crazy to think that like he's like my
grandpa would would would be trying to
explain to his father he's like you can
get a taxi cab and it's great and his
father's probably like water tiger I was
gonna get a horse
you know what's funny left you know for
Tigers one-year birthday yeah
so my mother like she has problems like
driving and stuff and then so my moms
like do you think come pick me up on my
counter be setting up for Tigers
birthday all day at the house ready oh
my what I could do is I can send it over
to you she's like what's that I'll send
a driver to your house they'll come and
pick you up and tell you you sound
bawling no 10-shot like a boy it's your
mom you sound like like $13 you know
cause I'll kill me now okay and all you
have to do is at this time come out of
your house because I'm gonna plug your
address in' and you just have to step
out of your house and the person will be
there and then when there was at that
time she was like where's the driver
I'm like are you outside of the house
and she was like yeah and I'm like is
there a car there she's like yeah this
is weird guy just part of my house what
if she think there's supposed to be like
a big black Lincoln I don't know I was
like I was like the Jew that he waved
when he was waving to me and I'm like
that's your car I'm gonna did you open
the car door she goes no she was all I'm
gonna do that right now she was
expecting an Escalade the driver with
the [ __ ] earpieces your mom uber
black that's true yeah yeah you didn't
give her the SUV one or whatever you
sent like a red Honda Civic yeah yeah
it's so crazy no such as I open the
thing and then I can over here on the
phone outlet hey are you Lillian she's
like she knows my yeah cuz you just get
in the car she's like oh that's funny I
was thinking about what were the other
day five six seven maybe ten years ago
you be if you told somebody who told
yourself like oh man you're not gonna do
can a random person that's not connected
to a cup company there's gonna pick you
up in their personal car and take you to
your house like I would never do that
Airbnb you're gonna stay in someone's
yeah personal house in their bed and
we're like now my uh going to McDonald's
yeah I still judge people
with Airbnb I go I actually booked a
Airbnb and while I'm there I'm judging
them like how can you lend your [ __ ]
house to strangers I judge them what are
you do I'm like your bed is so
comfortable you don't know what I could
be doing right now
oh my god that's weird I never thought
about that you're like letting people
have sex in your personal bed right and
I do [ __ ] the bed I do cuz I paid for
it Oh Airbnb get all the value I can't
[Music]
[Music]